I bet there's a hundred answers to this
question but in the end the thing that
matters most to me and if you think
about it I bet matters most to you which
is your family and your extended network
of friends in the end that is super
important so while we get wrapped around
the axle of doing whatever we're doing
it is really important to remember that
that's what matters most I'll say the
other thing is perspective and this has
been one of the lights of being married
to a neurosurgeon okay what we do in
business is important it's incredibly
important it's important to the
employees of HP to our VARs but no one
gets hurt at HP no one dies and so
remembering what's really important is I
think critical and I'll tell you a
little story which I've told on a number
of occasions so one of my closest
friends from Harvard Business School who
was in my section had a great career in
Los Angeles and has two children who are
about the same age as my children and
her 24 year old went into the Green
Berets and was killed in afghanistan in
june so when things seem pretty tough
remember your 24 year old did not get
killed in afghanistan so i think you've
just got to remember what actually
matters here and it's great to be
wrapped up in work it is terrific but in
the end that is the perspective of what
is really really important here honestly
and I will say when I lost the
governor's race it was hard to have that
perspective because it's what it could
have should have if I'd done this if I'd
done that you know maybe it would have
turned out differently in the end
nothing really bad happened i lost the
governor's race and you in you know my
family was intact my husband was a
menial you just have to remember and
then last but not least i would say your
reputation you have to be known as high
integrity doing what you say saying what
you mean because everything can go away
and if you still have your integrity
intact and so often at ebay at HP you
know I often ask what is the right thing
to do here and it's challenging because
the right thing to do is quite different
for cultures and I always used to say to
our teams it may be different in
different countries but if your mother
or your father or someone you love your
children were reading the New York Times
and they knew what you were doing would
they be proud or if they were sitting in
the eve of the conference room watching
the decision-making process would they
be proud of you and that's the ultimate
question whether you're you know from
Asia or from Latin America or for Europe
usually having that notion of what would
your parents think transverses all those
cultural norms about what's acceptable
and what's not so I think those are
those are the three things that I'd
point to right away